[MILLENIUM Les images que vous voyez
ici, ce sont celles d’une des plus
grandes simulations d’Univers virtuel
jamais réalisée, la simulation Millenium.
Les tâches de couleur représentent la
concentration de la matière aux
différents endroits de l’Univers.
Et comme vous pouvez le constater, cette matière
semble former des structures bien particulières.
On observe comme une toile cosmique, constituée
de filaments dont la taille peut atteindre des
centaines de millions d’années lumières.
Aux intersections de ces filaments,
des zones où se concentre la matière, et dans
lesquelles on trouve des grappes de galaxies.
Eh oui nous observons ici l’Univers
à une échelle absolument gigantesque.
Chaque minuscule point lumineux que vous
voyez ici, ça n’est pas une étoile, non,
il s’agit d’une galaxie tout entière,
une galaxie comme nôtre Voie lactée.]
Evidemment, ceci n’est qu’une simulation,
mais on a de très bonnes raisons
de penser que ce que vous avez vu
là est représentatif de la structure de notre
Univers dans son ensemble. Alors aujourd’hui,
voyons comment il est possible de connaitre et
de simuler l’Univers à ces échelles gigantesques.
[jingle]
Commençons par un peu d’historique.
Pendant très longtemps, on a pensé
que l’Univers se limitait à ce qu’on
voyait au-dessus de nos têtes la nuit:
des étoiles un peu partout, et notamment
regroupées au sein cette grande traînée
pâle dans le ciel nocturne qu’on appelle
la Voie lactée. Et puis rien de plus.
Jusqu’au début du XXième siècle, on ne parlait
pas de galaxie, le concept n’existait pas. Il
a fallu en effet attendre les années
1920 pour que l’astronome Edwin Hubble
mesure la distance qui nous sépare de qu’on
appelait à l’époque la nébuleuse d’Andromède.
[ANDROMEDE Et que l’on réalise alors que
celle-ci se trouvait beaucoup beaucoup plus
loin que tout ce qu’on avait pu imaginer.
Que cette nébuleuse était une sorte de
voie lactée n°2, mais située à plus de
2 millions d’années-lumières de nous.]
Et c’est ainsi qu’on a peu à peu commencé à
réaliser que l’Univers tout entier était rempli de
ces paquets d’étoiles qu’on a appelé les galaxies.
Aujourd’hui évidemment, avec les instruments
modernes d’observations, des galaxies on en voit
partout et on en connait un très grand nombre.
[HUBBLE Avec des clichés comme celui-ci,
pris par le télescope spatial Hubble,
on peut estimer qu’il existerait des centaines de
milliards de galaxies dans l’Univers observable.]
Donc vu depuis la Terre il semble qu’il
y ait des galaxies un peu partout dans
le ciel. Mais est-ce vraiment le
cas ? Comment sont-elles réparties
dans l’Univers globalement, si on pouvait
prendre du recul et les observer toutes ?
Est-ce qu’il y a des coins à galaxies,
qui en contiennent plus que d’autres
? Comme il y a des coins à champignons
dans les forêts. Ou au contraire est-ce qu’elles
sont réparties de façon relativement homogène ?
Une hypothèse naturelle ce serait de penser
qu’elles sont distribuées de façon aléatoire.
[ALEATOIRE Par exemple si ce disque représente
une portion de l’Univers visible, et que je tire
des points au hasard dedans pour représenter
les galaxies, j’obtiens un truc de ce genre.
Il y en a un peu partout. Évidemment par
coïncidence on a quelques endroits qui
en contiennent un peu plus. Mais dans l’ensemble
c’est assez homogène. Et ce serait plutôt naturel
de penser qu’à grande échelle, la répartition des
galaxies dans l’Univers ressemble un peu à ça.]
Sauf que depuis quelques dizaines d’années
maintenant, on sait qu’il n’en est rien.
Les galaxies sont en réalité réparties
d’une façon bien spécifique dans l’espace.
Pour s’en convaincre, il faut être capable
de mesurer et de représenter la position des
galaxies dans un volume suffisant.
Et il faut vraiment le faire en 3D,
on ne peut pas juste regarder les
galaxies dans le ciel et en faire
une simple carte. Il faut qu’on ait une idée de
la distance à laquelle elle se situent de nous.
Et connaître cette distance, c’est un
peu plus compliqué que juste faire une
photo. Mais il y a une solution.
On sait que les galaxies les plus
lointaines s’éloignent le plus vite,
à cause de l’expansion de l’Univers,
et cela se traduit dans leur couleur. Les
galaxies lointaines paraitront plus rouges.
Donc en mesurant avec suffisamment
de précision leur spectre lumineux,
on peut estimer leur vitesse d’éloignement, et
donc leur distance à nous. C’est ce qu’on appelle
la méthode du décalage vers le rouge. Et c’est ce
qui permet de reconstituer leur position en 3D.
Pour mieux comprendre la répartition
des galaxies dans l’Univers, il nous
faut donc appliquer cette méthode sur
un volume suffisant de l’Univers. Une
des premières tentatives de ce type
a commencé dans les années 80 sous la
direction des astronomes Margaret Geller et
John Huchra. On appelle cela le relevé CfA2.
Pour l’établir, nos astronomes ont mesuré
la position et la couleur de 18000 galaxies
situées dans une bande de ciel de quelques
degrés. Et comme on a à la fois leur position
dans le ciel et leur distance, la région ainsi
couverte est un volume de forme un peu conique.
[CfA2 Vous voyez ici une figure publiée en 1989
qui représente la position de galaxies mesurées
dans ce cône, jusqu’à des distances de près
de 700 millions d’années lumières. Et comme
vous pouvez le constater, la distribution
de ces galaxies est loin d’être uniforme.
Elles semblent s’agglutiner dans certaines zones,
et d’autres au contraire sont presque vides. Comme
si la galaxies se rassemblaient sur la surface de
grosses bulles. Et la grande structure allongée
qui traverse le champ d’observation
ici a été baptisée «Le Grand Mur».]
Alors attention ne vous méprenez pas, les
galaxies sont pas entassées les unes sur
les autres d’une façon qui bloquerait
le passage. Mais on a dans cette zone
une concentration anormalement élevée de galaxies.
Ce mur de galaxies fait une taille de plusieurs
centaines de millions d’années lumières,
pour une épaisseur de seulement 16
millions d’années lumières. Comme
si toutes ces galaxies avaient décidé de se
rassembler dans cette fine tranche de l’espace.
Le relevé CfA2 a été l’un des premiers à
mettre en évidence ce genre de structures.
Mais il y a eu depuis bien d’autres campagnes
d’observations qui ont permis d’établir des
relevés de position encore plus importants,
jusqu’à des distances toujours plus grandes.
[2dF Par exemple le relevé 2dF, établi
entre 1997 et 2002, et dont vous voyez
ici une représentation des résultats. Il
répertorie au total la position d’environ 200
000 galaxies, et a révélé des structures jusqu’à
2 milliards d’années lumières de distance.]
Depuis les années 2000, c’est l’expérience SDSS
pour Sloan Digital Sky Survey qui a pris le relai,
et ce grâce à un télescope
spécialement dédié à cela.
[SDSS Vous voyez ici une reconstitution en 3D de
la position de dizaines de milliers de galaxies,
parmi plus d’un million qui ont été mesurées
et caractérisées par le télescope SDSS.]
En 2003, la collaboration SDSS a
notamment annoncé la découverte
de ce qu’on appelle le grand mur
de Sloan, un autre mur de galaxies
qui lui serait 2 à 3 fois plus grand
que le mur de CfA2 dont on a parlé.
Toutes ces observations nous peignent
donc l’Univers comme une sorte de
grande toile d’araignée cosmique,
constituée de murs de galaxies,
de filaments et entre lesquelles se trouvent
d’immenses zones largement dépeuplées.
D’ailleurs notre galaxie, la Voie
lactée, se trouverait elle-même sur
un de ces filaments baptisé
le filament Poisson-Baleine,
du nom des constellations qu’il faut
viser dans le ciel pour l’observer.
On voit donc avec tout cela qu’on semble très
loin d’une répartition homogène des galaxies
dans l’Univers, ce qui semblait pourtant une
hypothèse raisonnable. Mais alors comment
est-ce qu’on peut expliquer la formation de ces
structures étonnantes ? Pourquoi une répartition
si particulière ? Qu’est-ce qui explique
la taille de ces murs et de ces filaments ?
Eh bien pour le comprendre, il faut
se tourner vers le modèle du Big Bang,
pour essayer de simuler l’évolution de l’Univers.
[jingle]
Commençons par la vue d’ensemble. On sait
aujourd’hui qu’il y a 13,8 milliards d’années,
l’Univers était dans un état
très dense et très chaud,
et qu’il s’est depuis dilaté et
refroidit. Une des confirmations
expérimentales les plus spectaculaires de
ce scénario, c’est le rayonnement fossile.
Il s’agit d’une sorte de photographie de l’Univers
tel qu’il était 380 000 ans après le big bang,
à l’époque de la formation des premiers atomes. Et
cela se manifeste aujourd’hui par un rayonnement
électromagnétique, faible mais qu’on peut
observer dans toutes les directions du ciel.
Ce rayonnement a une caractéristique bien précise
: il correspond à celui qu’émettrait un corps
ayant une température de 2.73 K, donc seulement
2,73 degrés au-dessus du zéro absolu. Et ce qui
est fascinant, c’est que ce rayonnement
est extrêmement homogène. Quelle que soit
la direction du ciel dans laquelle on regarde
il semble quasiment identique : 2.73 Kelvins.
Cette uniformité traduit qu’à l’époque
où ce rayonnement a été émis, donc 380
000 ans après le big bang, la répartition de
la matière présente à l’époque devait elle
aussi être extrêmement homogène. Car oui à
ce moment là il n’y avait pas de planètes,
pas d’étoiles, pas de galaxies. Juste du gaz un
peu partout : de l’hydrogène et un peu d’helium.
Et si on en croit l’uniformité
du rayonnement fossile,
la densité de ce gaz devait être quasiment
là-même partout dans l’Univers. Mettons
des chiffres sur cette idée, parce
qu’on peut préciser ce ‘quasiment’.
[CMB Le rayonnement fossile ait
été découvert dans les années 60,
et à l’époque il paraissait complètement
homogène. Et il a fallu attendre plus de
30 ans pour détecter les premières très
légères inhomogénéités de sa température.
Plus précisément, on sait aujourd’hui
que ce rayonnement a une température de
2.728 K plus ou moins 0.002 K. C’est
ce que traduisent les variations de
couleur qu’on voit sur les cartes de
ce genre. 2.728 plus ou moins 0.00,
ça veut dire que ce rayonnement
fossile est homogène à 0.1% près.]
Cela signifie qu’à l’époque où il a été émis,
380 000 ans après le big bang, il pouvait
exister de très légères variations de densité
de matière dans l’Univers, un peu plus par-ci,
un peu moins par là. Mais qu’elles devaient
certainement être du même ordre, environ 0.1%.
La densité du gaz était extrêmement homogène,
avec juste d’infimes perturbations dans la
répartition de la matière. Comme des petites
rides, dont on pense qu’elles trouvent
leur origine dans les fluctuations
quantiques de l’Univers primordial.
Mais si à cette époque, il
y a 13.8 milliards d’années,
la répartition de la matière dans l’Univers
était si homogène, comment se fait-il que
ce ne soit plus le cas maintenant. Qu’on ait
aujourd’hui des zones pleines de galaxies,
des murs, des filaments, et à côté
d’autres régions quasiment vides ?
Eh bien c’est parce que la force de gravité a
peu à peu accentuée les différences de densité,
et amplifié les rides minuscules qui
existaient à l’époque, pour donner ces
grandes structures qu’on observe aujourd’hui.
Alors voyons comment ça a pu se produire.
[ATTRACTION Imaginez que je prenne quelques objets
massifs que je disperse dans l’espace. Disons des
galaxies mais ça pourrait être autre chose, comme
de simples nuages de gaz. Puisque la gravité est
une force attractive, ces masses vont s’attirer et
finir par se rapprocher les unes sur les autres.]
Donc aurait envie de penser que toutes les
galaxies de l’Univers devraient maintenant
se retrouver groupées dans un seul coin,
les unes sur les autres. Sauf qu’il y
a aussi l’expansion de l’Univers
qui dilate toutes les distances,
et donc qui va en quelque sorte
s’opposer en partie à l’attraction.
Qu’est-ce qu’il se passe si on combine les
deux phénomènes : expansion et attraction.
Eh bien c’est quelque chose qu’on peut
calculer. On prend un Univers en expansion,
dont on connait l’évolution par
la théorie du Big Bang. On balance
dedans plein de particules massives qui
représentent par exemple des galaxies,
ou des morceaux de galaxies,
et on voit ce qu’il se passe.
Pour calculer l’attraction que ces
galaxies exercent les unes sur les autres,
pas besoin de sortir l’artillerie lourde, la
gravité de Newton fait largement l’affaire.
On calcule les forces comme on l’apprend au
lycée. Mais on ajoute l’effet de l’expansion
de l’Univers et on a une belle équation pour
représenter l’évolution de nos galaxies.
Manque de bol cette équation est impossible
à résoudre directement par le calcul,
même sans l’expansion d’ailleurs.
C’est un problème bien connu qu’on
appelle le problème à N corps.
Si on a juste deux corps qui
s’attirent, on sait calculer exactement leur
trajectoire. A partir de 3 c’est impossible,
ça devient chaotique. Et le mieux qu’on puisse
faire, ce sont des simulations numériques.
Sur le papier, le principe est simple. On
part d’une distribution initiale de galaxies,
et on va les faire se déplacer petit à
petit. A chaque étape de la simulation,
on calcule les forces qui
s’exercent sur chaque galaxie,
on la déplace un peu en fonction. Et on
recommence, autant de fois que nécessaire.
La seule difficulté, c’est que chaque
galaxie subit l’influence de toutes les
autres galaxies. Donc il faut calculer
toutes les forces qui s’exercent entre
toutes les galaxies. Si on a N
galaxies dans notre simulation,
on a en gros N^2 forces à calculer à chaque
étape. Donc ça prend vite beaucoup de temps.
[TURNER79 Les premières simulations de
ce genre ont été réalisées à la fin des
années 70. En prenant quelques milliers de
masses dans un volume représentant un cube
environ 100 millions d’années lumières,
on arrive qualitativement à observer des
premiers agrégats de galaxies qui
rappellent la structure des amas.]
Au fur à mesure des recherches sur le sujet,
bien sûr les ordinateurs sont
devenus de plus en plus puissants,
mais les algorithmes aussi ont été améliorés et
ont permis de beaucoup gagner en temps de calcul.
Par exemple l’algorithme dit de Barnes-Hut
est en NlogN au lieu d’être en N^2. Ca veut
dire qu’avec disons 1000000 de galaxies,
il faudra quelques millions d’opérations,
au lieu de 1000 milliards. Gain substantiel
quand même, au prix d’un sacrifice limité
dans la précision de la simulation.
[EVOLUTION La figure que vous voyez
ici montre au cours du temps l’évolution
de la taille des simulations, exprimées en
nombre de particules simulées.
Alors attention on emploie le
terme de particules pour désigner les
masses qu’on met dans la simulation.
On parle pas de particules fondamentales
genre des électrons. Ici ce qu’on appelle
une particule c’est une galaxie, ou une
masse représentant un morceau de galaxie.
Sur ce graphique, attention en ordonnée l’échelle
est logarithmique, donc ça progresse de
façon exponentielle. On voit qu’à chaque
décennie la taille de la simulation
a été multipliée environ par 100.]
Une des étapes marquantes de cette évolution
a notamment été en 2005 la publication des
résultats de la simulation modestement
intitulé Millenium Simulation. Celle-ci
a été réalisée par un consortium
international d’astrophysiciens,
au moyen d’un super ordinateur situé en Allemagne,
et qui aura passé un mois complet sur cette tâche.
Ce calcul a simulé 10 milliards de particules,
chacune ayant une masse d’environ 1 milliard de
fois celle du Soleil. Cela veut dire que dans la
simulation, une particule ne représente pas une
galaxie tout entière, mais seulement une toute
petite fraction, environ 1/500e de galaxie.
Pour initialiser la simulation, les
chercheurs ont utilisé une distribution
initiale homogène des particules, avec
juste de toutes petites perturbations
dont les caractéristiques ont été déduites
des fluctuations du rayonnement fossile.
On part des minuscules rides de plus ou
moins 0.1% dont on a parlé, et puisque
l’attraction gravitationnelle
va amplifier les différences,
on s’attend à ce que ces petites
fluctuations soient en quelque
sortes les graines des grandes structures qui
se développeront au cours de la simulation.
Le volume couvert par la simulation
Millenium représente une cube de 2
milliards d’années lumières de
côté, au sein duquel on a pu
observer la formation progressives
d’environ 20 millions de galaxies.
Et l’extrait que je vous ai passé au tout
début représente l’état de cet Univers
virtuel à l’issue de la simulation.
On peut y visualiser ces structures
filamentaires si caractéristiques,
aux intersections desquelles on
trouve une concentration importante
de matière, représentée ici en jaune.
Toutes ces structures ont des tailles typiques
de centaines de millions d’années lumières,
et elles semblent parfaitement raccord
avec ce qu’on a pu observer dans les
catalogues de relevés comme CfA2, 2dF ou SDSS.
[SPRINGEL2006 C’est en tout cas ce qui ressort de
cette image qui compare des tranches
de la simulation Millenium, en rouge,
a des représentations des galaxies des
différents relevés en bleu et violet.
On ne retrouve pas exactement la
même image puisqu’il y a une part
d’aléatoire dans la simulation, mais
comme vous pouvez le constater : on
a le même genre de structures,
dont la taille semble similaire.]
Très bien, mais dire que ça ressemble, ça
n’est pas vraiment suffisant, on ne peut pas se
contenter de dire que visuellement ça se semble
coller. Il nous faut des moyens de faire cette
comparaison avec des données chiffrées. Alors
voyons le genre d’analyses que l’on peut faire.
Pour faire une comparaison quantitative entre
d’un côté les résultats des simulations,
et de l’autre les structures qu’on
retrouve dans les observations,
on veut d’une certaine manière mesurer
le degré de regroupement des galaxies.
A quel point elles sont dispersées ou au
contraire proches les unes des autres.
Pour cela il existe un moyen :
ce qu’on appelle la fonction de
corrélation. C’est une courbe qui mesure en
quelque sorte à quel point on a des chances
de trouver une nouvelle galaxie quand
on s’éloigne d’une galaxie existante.
[CORRELATION Si les galaxies étaient réparties
aléatoirement, la fonction de corrélation serait
nulle. Quelle que soit la distance la chance
de trouver une nouvelle galaxie est la même.
Avec des galaxies qui présentent
un certain degré de regroupement,
la fonction de corrélation va être décroissante.
On a beaucoup de chance de trouver une galaxie
proche d’une galaxie existante, et cela
va en diminuant quand on s’éloigne.
Et la forme exacte courbe que l’on obtient permet
de caractériser plus précisément la
nature des structures que l’on forme.]
Ces courbes de fonction de corrélation, on
peut les calculer précisément à partir des
données réelles issues des relevés de
galaxies, mais aussi en utilisant les
résultats des simulations. Et on peut comparer
les deux pour voir si ça colle si bien que ça.
[MILLENIUM La figure que vous voyez ici fait
cette comparaison avec en bleu les corrélations
pour les «vraies» galaxies, et en rouge les
résultats de la simulation Millenium. Et vous
voyez que les deux sont en excellent accord. Ce
qui confirme que les structures formées dans la
simulation Millenium sont très représentatives
de celles qu’on observe vraiment dans l’Univers.]
Depuis la simulation Millenium, qui date quand
même de 2005, plein de nouvelles simulations ont
vu le jour, profitant de la puissance toujours
croissante des ordinateurs. L’une des plus
récentes et spectaculaires, c’est la simulation
Uchuu, qui veut dire «Univers» en japonais.
[UCHUU Vous pouvez admirer ici un extrait du
déroulement cette simulation. Elle utilise au
total 2000 milliards de particules,
soit 200 fois plus que Millenium,
dans un volume d’univers correspondant à un
cube de 10 milliards d’années-lumières de côté.
Une fois la simulation achevée, voici un
extrait de ce qu’on obtient : on retrouve
bien sûr les structures filamentaires
dont on a déjà parlé. Les zones de vide,
et celles de forte concentration de matière.]
Si ça vous intéresse vous pouvez télécharger
sur leur site les résultats détaillés de la
simulation Uchuu. Juste l’ensemble
des données pèse 2 pétaoctets. Donc
il faut faudra un bon millier de
disques durs pour tout stocker.
Alors évidemment on pourrait encore rajouter
plus de particules pour multiplier la taille
de l’Univers simulé. Mais on y gagnerait pas
forcément grand chose. Pour améliorer les
simulations il existe deux autres voies : gagner
en résolution, et modéliser plus de phénomènes.
C’est par exemple ce que fait
la simulation Illustris TNG,
qui est en quelque sorte la
descendante de la simulation Millenium.
Quand je parle de gagner en résolution,
cela veut dire utiliser des particules
représentant de plus petites quantités
de matière, pour avoir plus de finesse,
quitte à modéliser des régions
éventuellement plus petites de l’espace.
[TNG50 Dans la simulation IllustrisTNG50, on
se concentre sur un petit cube de 50 millions
d’années lumières, mais avec des particules
de seulement 50 000 masses solaires. Ce qui
permet de suivre de façon détaillée
la façon dont se forment les galaxies,
comme on le voit sur cet extrait vidéo
qui zoome sur un de ces phénomènes.]
Mais comme je l’ai dit, une autre piste
d’amélioration consiste à modéliser plus
de phénomènes physiques. Les équations de
simulation que je vous ai décrites tout
à l’heure restent assez rudimentaire,
puisqu’on ne traitait que l’interaction
gravitationnelle. Ca revient à traiter
toute la matière comme de la matière noire.
Mais on peut essayer de faire mieux que ça. Ainsi
dans les simulations du consortium IllustrisTNG,
on trouve non seulement les interactions
gravitationnelles, mais également le
comportement du gaz, le rayonnement, les
effets de magnétisme ou d’hydrodynamique.
[TNG300 Ca leur a permis par exemple
dans la simulation IllustrisTNG300
d’estimer les fonctions de corrélation de
façon indépendante pour les différentes
formes de matière : les étoiles, les
trous noirs, le gaz, la matière noire,
etc. Et on voit qu’elles ont des
répartitions légèrement différentes.]
Pour comparer ces simulations aux observations, on
ne peut plus se contenter des relevés de galaxies,
qui ne nous renseignent que sur la
matière lumineuse. Il faut aussi
une idée de comment se répartissent le gaz
interstellaire, ou encore la manière noire.
Heureusement il existe d’autres
méthodes d’observation, comme les
effets de lentilles gravitationnelles,
ou encore ce qu’on appelle les forêts
Lyman-alpha des quasars. Il faudra un
jour que je vous parle des quasars.
En les combinant, ces différentes techniques
associées aux catalogues des galaxies permettent
de se faire une image assez précise de la façon
dont est distribuée la matière dans l’Univers,
et notamment comment elle varie aux
différentes échelles d’observations.
En conclusion, on voit que les simulations et
les observations permettent de mieux
comprendre la structure de l’Univers,
et comment celle-ci a pu se former à partir
de minuscules fluctuations primordiales.
Et ça nous renseigne aussi au
passage sur les mécanismes à
l’oeuvre lors des premiers instants du
Big-Bang qui ont donné naissance à ces
fluctuations, ancêtres des grandes
structures de la toile cosmiques.
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui. Comme toujours,
plus d’infos ci-dessous notamment le billet de
blog et aussi le serveur Discord : n’hésitez
pas à le rejoindre pour continuer la
discussion, le lien est en description.
Un merci particulier à Maxime
Trebitsch qui est astrophysicien,
et qui a bien voulu répondre à mes questions
pour préparer le script de cette vidéo. Et
moi sur ce je vous dit à très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos. A bientôt. POSE MINIATURE